tonight a grieving mother is dealing
with even more loss after things that
belonged to her late son were stolen
four-year-old kaden machim died after a
fire back in december in the east valley
victoria saha joining us live with his
mother's plea to the community in a
story you will only see on 8 news now
denise and brian you can clearly see
that there is a keep out and no
trespassing sign here on this burnt
mobile home but the trespassers still
went behind this mobile home into a shed
back there and took whatever they could
in fact just as my photographer and i
were pulling up to this location a few
minutes ago we came across a trespasser
but they ran off as soon as they saw us
i lost my son my dogs my home everything
that i owned rhiannon machum had just
finished moving everything that she
could save from the fire into her shed
from her storage unit the lock was cut
come in and it's just ransacked items
that belonged to her precious
three-year-old son kaiden were stolen
anything that kaden touched i would like
to keep surveillance video from her
neighbor showing people walking out of
her property and her neighbor even tried
following them items clearly in their
hands maechum's life was turned upside
down the morning of december 6. when she
woke up surrounded by flames she was
able to make it out but kayden didn't it
feels like i've been sentenced to an
eternity of misery
machem shows us what is left of her
charred mobile home still finding stuff
that belonged to
i kaiden find a pair of socks or
something that's like
not melted
it's like christmas which is why the
thought of people taking the bare
minimum of what she was able to save
from that fire is unfathomable for her i
don't understand how people's
thought processes like oh i see a burnt
house let me just
break in and
steal whatever i can
fire officials did say this fire was
accidental as surveillance videos showed
cayden was playing with a torch right
before that fire started maichum is
working on a police report but first
needs to list out everything that needs
to be stolen she's urging everyone in
this area to be on the lookout for
anything that may belong to cayden
reporting from the east valley tonight
victoria zaha live local now